[Music]
how do i overcome a toxic relationship
with a parent so we can let go of our
contentious past
it will require the cooperation of the
parent
and if that fails then it might require
boundary setting yeah
uh you know it's so easy for us to
believe that we can actually change
other people and it's impossible
the only people we can change ours is
ourselves and even that's damn hard
right so what makes us think we can
actually change other human beings we
can't that's why i love al-anon by the
way you know like which is the support
group for people who are in relationship
with addicts and alcoholics it's because
it says don't bother trying to change
that person work on yourself yeah and
that's the only way that i think you're
going to be able to live in in a
positive relationship with that person
if the toxicity becomes too
self-damaging or just not too
self-damaging but just damaging
then you have to erect the proper
boundaries to protect yourself and the
relationship
like a good boundary will protect the
relationship
from imploding right so all that stuff
is you know um really important but it's
to give up the idea that she can
actually change
uh but to maybe create the environment
in which the possibility of change would
be more
probable um but i think people are often
like how do i what they're really asking
is how do i change that person right you
want to make this relationship better
and you can't yeah i think like when i
think about familiar familial
relationships that i have kind of issues
with
uh the question i ask is how can i
accept that person for who they are and
like not patronize them
but um be agreeable with them as much as
i can as long as it doesn't go outside
of my values like
we were just in ohio
for thanksgiving and um my brother uh
him and i were like putting heads the
whole time
and there was one particular time where
um he was like you know you guys should
start selling minimalist t-shirts
and i'm like you think we is the minimum
should start selling t-shirts he's like
yeah he's like
why wouldn't you and i'm like because
i'm not really passionate about it i
don't feel like i can do a t-shirt
better
um you know our whole thing is kind of
anti-consumerism
and like i mean he really like came at
me because i shot down his idea right
and what i realized later
is if i would have taken the approach of
like oh what my brother's trying to do
he's trying to add value to my life he's
trying to give me an idea
that um he's trying to contribute toward
towards my life essentially so there's a
way that i could look at him and be like
oh t-shirts interesting tell me more
tell me more or i'll yeah so how would
you do a t-shirt and like really get him
involved instead of shutting him down
and the same thing goes with my mother
where you know she will um she's been
she's like would send me a bunch of
conspiracy theory stuff oh boy and i
used to look at it and say
hey
here's why you might not want to take
you know this this video is gossip
uh and she would and it seemed to change
her oh thank you for sharing that what
do you think about this video and then
i'd respond back well here's what you
want to consider what about this one and
then i realized i'm like oh wait a
minute i'm just enabling her
you know she doesn't want to do the work
to analyze these things herself so she
wants me to do the work for her and i'm
not willing to do that
um so she stopped sending me videos and
then recently started sending me the
conspiracy stuff just listen to the last
10 minutes of this you know promise me
you'll listen to this oh yeah but that
might require a boundary and that's
exactly what has happened so
with my mom i'm like hey please don't
send this stuff
and then she sent it one more time and i
was like mom i love you
i know that you're trying to help
and this is my way of showing her hey i
accept who you are as a person but
there's something that i need to like be
clear on right now and it's that i'm not
going to watch any of these videos
so setting that boundary while
showing my mom i accept her oh that's an
interesting thought sounds like an
interesting video title i'm still not
going to watch it though so showing her
that like there is a level of acceptance
but also setting that boundary has
helped her and i
get along much much better even this
last time we were together like i don't
think we've gotten along this well in a
long time yeah but if it's an abusive
really toxic relationship that that
might require
a provisional
uh
boundary that might have to require
separating from that person of course
yeah
loving them from a distance yes because
to try to change someone is to unlove
them i think we realize that we we
believe in conditional love in our
culture hey i love you ian if you change
these seven things about you and it's
like well that's not love that just in
fact that's hate in a way it's hey if i
can change you to make you exactly how
the person i want you to be like you're
some sort of barbie doll or something
then i will love you but love doesn't
work like that love has to do with
seeing someone for who they are without
trying to change them accepting them for
who they are you may not like every
piece of them now the other thing to
consider here is maybe the toxic person
in the relationship is you
not you specifically yeah but thank you
but quite often what happens in a toxic
relationship is the two people are
perfectly fine on their own there's no
toxicity there but when they come
together they create some sort of
chemical reaction and it's easy to blame
that other person
look this explosion happened because of
you no it happened because of me and you
us coming together created this yeah
your mom wouldn't be sending you these
these uh conspiracy videos if you didn't
exist right yeah now and if you didn't
set up the boundary then you would be
adding to the toxicity if you're like oh
yeah well let me argue these seven
points against that or whatever right
especially i could see danny doing this
as an eight
he could well let me actually shut this
down i'll describe to you why you're
wrong or whatever yeah or bex might do
that here here's a actually the right
way to do this is this right
and and what where we go with that is
we're accidentally without knowing it
creating
an environment that becomes toxic right
yeah we always have to own what our
peace might be oh yeah well one of the
things that for me creates that toxicity
that makes me the toxic person
is that when my mom does something to me
i say oh she doesn't understand she
doesn't get me she doesn't consider me
and what i realized is like wait a
minute
like am i considering her am i trying to
get her and as soon as i started to look
outward with that like that is when it
started to get a little bit more calm
where i'm like oh okay like she has her
own stuff i'm gonna try and respect her
stuff her perspective and then maybe
she'll do the same for me and then it
has for the most part worked yeah yeah
yeah that's beautiful
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free